et
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette première
émission de l'année une émission un peu
spéciale puisque nous reviendrons avec
michel laugier président de la
communauté d'agglomération sur les
grands événements qui ont marqué saint
quentin en yvelines et chaud qui voit la
marque et en 2015
voilà c'est tout de suite c'est
maintenant c'est par là 2014 fut riche
en événements et bien d'autres arrivent
encore en 2015 et au delà au fait le
point tout de suite avec le président de
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
j'ai le b michel logique
alors déjà le moment important de 2014
sélection de nouveaux présidente avec
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle majorité à la
tête de cette intercommunalité
un changement qui n'était pas intervenu
ici depuis quarante deux ans en revanche
si le changement est et demi au niveau
de l'intercommunalité c'est la stabilité
qui a prévalu dans les sept communes de
l'agglo lors des dernières élections
municipales mais de 2014 on retiendra
également le progrès non forts de
l'année 2014 de corne de ses
délibérations du vélodrome c'était fall
janvier il ya d'abord eu une journée
inaugurale qu un week end portes
ouvertes qui a permis à 20000 saint
quentinois de découvrir les buts
ensuite a été marquée aussi par la
poursuite de grands événements sur la
ville avec l'arrivée
du siège de mercedes france sur notre
territoire ce sont aussi les travaux les
travaux de rénovation du pôle gare de
saint-quentin
c'est aussi le développement économique
avec la prise de possession le et jc de
son duvet les meubles sur l'avenue du
centre n'oubliera pas le kiosque le
portail culturel des peuples et par la
communauté d'agglomération et son
système de billetterie en lien avec la
plupart des salles du territoire en
effet reçu le label d'argent des
territoires innovants au forum des
interconnectés en décembre
2015 sur une allée d'importance pour 50
en bim
il s'agira notamment passé connaître le
devenir de notre intercommunalité
la loi impose en effet que les
intercommunalités réunissent désormais
deux cent mille habitants minimum
l'agglo en a aujourd'hui 150 milles elle
va donc de voir s'agrandir
soit nous sommes fondu dans une très
grande intercommunalité à 800 milles
habitants sont tous cas aujourd'hui
ce qui est proposé par l'état à travers
le préfet de région donc un territoire
qui partirait de coignières qui ré
jusqu'à vie sous la dent au banc bien su
50 à versailles saclay europ'essonne
territoire énorme dont personne ne veut
l'ensemble des conseils municipaux et
des intercommunalités concernées ont
fait part de leur opposition à ce projet
il s'agit maintenant de faire une contre
proposition et que très large majorité
se dégage
notre proposition tout simplement c'est
que au lieu d'une seule intercommunalité
à huit cent mille habitants
nous souhaitons nous trois grandes
intercommunalités une interco sur les
seuls qui réunirent et la caps et
europ'essonne une interco sur versailles
qui accueillerait vélizy et l'intercours
de saint quentin qui se développerait en
accueillant en accorder des communes de
l'ouest parisien à savoir plaisir les
clés et vitreux ainsi que les communes
de maurepas et de quoi dire
que dès le mois de janvier nous allons
inaugurer safran safran qui s'installe
dans les locaux laissés vacants par
nortel c'est à dire à cheval sur château
fort et sûr magny les hameaux et on
espère aussi que sur ce site intègre a
très vite l'école des mines
c'est aussi une migration de baxter le
technocentre renault va aussi grandir et
qu' il ya des travaux importants au sein
de cadets agricole sur lui en cours qui
va nous permettre de pouvoir accueillir
1500 collaborateurs supplémentaires
on voyait bien d'autres territoires
restent toujours très attractifs
et en 2015 c'est l'arrivée dès février
du nouveau directeur du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui va marquer
l'année culturelle nomi à le président
de la caisse qui est le ministre de la
culture
lionel masse et a jusqu'ici directeur du
théâtre de l'undd à vélizy vinci prendre
les rênes de la scène nationale de
souhaiter que le théâtre soit plus
ouvert plus attractif beaucoup plus
tournée vers l'extérieur qu'ils ne
l'étaient jusqu'à présent donc un
théâtre plus partagée par les saint
quentinois et j'espère aussi plus
fréquentes
au niveau du sport bien sûr on va
continuer à notre politique en direction
du golfe qui va nous emmener jusqu'en
2018 avec l'accueil de la ryder cup du
18 février au 22 février
nous allons accueillir les championnats
du monde de cyclisme sur piste
donc c'est vrai que c'est une vraie
réussite c'est une récompense aussi
c'est une fierté
quelques mois après l'inauguration de
notre vélodrome les autorités
internationales reconnaissent d'autres
sites comme un site capable de pouvoir
accueillir les championnats du monde
un rendez vous international
incontournable puisque dès les premiers
jours d'ouverture de la billetterie
70 % des billets ont été vendus
mais un autre rendez vous cycliste à la
portée internationale aura lieu
également cette année à saint quentin en
yvelines jacques chirac du parc basta
la grande nouveauté c'est que justement
pour la première fois il va partir du
parvis du vélodrome ça paraît d'antan
qu'on peut se donner du véritable
identité
paris brest paris 50 ha et n'existe pas
à quêter alors que la sphère le départ
depuis un site maintenant reconnue
partout monde va donner là aussi une
dimension à l'agglomération de saint
quentin
rappelons que le paris-brest-paris la
plus grande randonnée cyclotouriste au
monde puisqu'elle a réuni plus de 6000
participants venus de tous les pays
et en 2015 c'est le quartier du
vélodrome qui va le plus bouger nous
allons au cours de l'année 2015 à voir
la livraison des huit cent trente
logements qui sont tournés vers les
étudiants les jeunes travailleurs et les
chercheurs nous allons aussi accueillir
deux hôtels pardon devant le vélodrome
mais des projets vont bien entendu se
poursuivre sur chaque commune
c'est la poursuite de la zac de
l'aérostat c'est la poursuite aussi du
développement de villeroy sur guyancourt
ce sont de belles opérations aussi dans
le dans le coeur village de
manille les amours
puis c'est la poursuite aussi de
l'ordination des réaux sur elancourt
donc on va bien tous les territoires et
boum nos voisins le bretonneux aussi
nous sommes en train de mettre les les
derniers éléments de détail sur la zac
de la remise mai 2015 sera également une
année de réflexion et d'engagement du
grand projet à venir nous allons aussi
essayer d'avoir la maîtrise à travers
l'établissement font ce public foncier
des yvelines du terrain à falaise située
à aiguillon goût et qui devrait être
votre site qui accueillera dans l'année
à venir la ligne 18 oncle métro qui doit
relier orly jusqu'à versailles 2015 sera
également une année placée sous le signe
de l'économie dans un contexte de
diminution des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités
la caisse qui a dû revoir ses
attributions aux communes nous avons
voté à l'unanimité des membres du
conseil d'agglomération de nouveau pacte
financier qui 12 ans qui va nous
permettre pour les trois prochaines
années de pouvoir bâtir de budget avec
cohérence 2015 verra également la
signature du nouveau contrat de plan
etat-région lengelé notamment d'obtenir
les financements nécessaires à la
réalisation de grands projets tels que
la couverture de la n10 attrape
l'aménagement du carrefour de la malle
me donne à la verrière maurepas d'un
échangeur au bout de l'avenue des
garennes pour fluidifier la circulation
au rond-point des sangliers
mais la communauté d'agglomération
souhaite également un prolongement de la
ligne c du rer au moins jusqu'à la
verrière et que les trains express
régionaux puissent s'arrêter à saint
quentin en yvelines
des projets qui se feront dans la durée
sur lequel ne manquerons pas de revenir
voilà pour d'autres dossiers encore une
information avant de nous quitter
sachez que le petit quentin devient le
skim avec voilà il me reste à vous
souhaiter une très bonne année 2015 et à
bientôt